[Musica]
[Applauso]
c'è un'azione che tutti compiamo così
diffusa così naturale che la diamo per
scontata eppure danneggia noi e
l'ambiente
in questo misurino o del normale del
persino per lavatrice cosa succederebbe
se lo versassi nella boccia del
pesciolino rosso e cosa pensereste di me
sono un crudele non ho rispetto degli
animali
eppure è quello che facciamo tutti tutti
i giorni ogni volta che puliamo il bagno
ogni volta che facciamo una lavatrice
ogni volta che l'abbiamo i piatti solo
che non siamo consapevoli delle
conseguenze di questa azione dove va a
finire il detersivo petrolchimico che
utilizziamo nelle nostre case
quando scompare giù per gli scarichi nei
fiumi nei laghi nei mari e negli oceani
tranquilli nel misurino c'era del
colorante alimentare il pesciolino rosso
sta benissimo l'ho messo addirittura
finto per essere sicuro di non far
nessun danno da dieci anni la mia
missione è quella di insegnare alle
persone come pulire casa in modo sano e
naturale senza inquinare il pianeta
tutto iniziato quando ad angelo il mio
bambino all'epoca aveva un anno
iniziarono a comparire delle strane
macchioline rosse sul corpo
principalmente sulle braccia e poi sulle
gambe erano le stesse macchioline rosse
che avevo io e che mi costringevano
danni a continuare a riempirmi di pomate
iniziamo a girare per studi medici per
capire di che cosa si trattasse
finché un giorno dermatologo mi disse
macchioline di angelo il suo problema a
che fare con i detersivi più utilizzate
per lavare i suoi vestiti ma come il
detersivo che utilizzavo e io stesso
rivendevo e che portavo a casa perché
per prendermi cura di mio figlio era la
causa del suo problema
iniziamo ad utilizzare detersivi bio
alternativi e nel giro di qualche
settimana
il problema scomparire ma questa era
solo la punta dell'iceberg continuano ad
approfondire scoprì che non solo la
nostra salute era a rischio c'era un
problema di cui nessuno parlava
l'inquinamento causato dai detersivi
mi chiesi ma esiste un modo sano e
naturale di pulire che ci permetta di
non inquinare il nostro pianeta e la
risposta è sì esiste e vi assicuro che
da oggi non guarderete mai più il
mobiletto dei detersivi di casa vostra
con gli stessi occhi
se ci pensate bene e pieno di sostanze
inquinanti ed irritanti che se
utilizzata nel modo sbagliato avvelenano
i nostri mari prendiamo come esempio
detersivo per lavatrice la lavatrice è
in assoluto l'elettrodomestico che più
inquina i nostri mari ogni lavatrice a
fine lavaggio scarica in acqua 50 litri
di acqua sporca piena di detersivo di
coloranti che si staccano dai vestiti di
microplastiche che si staccano dai
vestiti dei nostri dai campi sintetici
se vi sembra poco 50 litri
vi dico che in realtà una lavatrice
inquina 176 mila litri di acqua è
l'equivalente di 140 vasche da bagno
significa che ogni volta che una
lavatrice scarica in acqua poi 50 litri
di acqua sporca servono 176 mila litri
di acqua per rendere no neutra quella
quantità di acqua sporcata dalla nostra
lavatrice e se anche questo vi sembra
poco in italia siamo 24,6 milioni di
famiglie e facciamo un totale di 6
miliardi di lavatrici ogni anno c'erano
lavatrici fatte con detersivi
principalmente petrolchimici che sono la
causa principale dell'inquinamento delle
lavatrici perché ogni volta che facciamo
una lavatrice scarichiamo il detersivo
che contiene additivi sbiancanti
coloranti pro fumanti
ogni anno in italia consumiamo 28
milioni di confezioni di questo
detersivo inquinante la maggior causa
del problema dell'inquinamento del
terzino rimane comunque il tensioattivo
il tentativo è la maggior causa del
fenomeno di eutrofizzazione dell'acqua
significa che ogni volta che il
tensioattivo petrochimico finisce
nell'acqua si scompone sostanze più
naturali come zolfo potassio
ma qui ci verrebbe anche da dire è una
buona notizia scarichiamo sostanze
naturali e sono il principale nutrimento
delle alghe e delle piante acquatiche
quindi bene dai ci possiamo rilassare un
attimo un'azione bella l'abbiamo fatta e
invece no perché queste sostanze
aumentano l'attività batterica delle
alghe che mangiano l'ossigeno presente
nell'acqua e di fatto uccidono i mari e
uccidono i pesci
potremmo riassumere tutto questo
inquinamento con un'unica immagine
questo è il nostro mare e il mare
mediterraneo
tutto questo produce ogni anno
l'inquinamento di questa quantità di
acqua la quantità di acqua del mare
mediterraneo che va dallo stretto di
gibilterra alla sicilia e stiamo
parlando solo dei detersivi per
lavatrice
ora proviamo a chiederci dove va a
finire il detersivo che ho appena
utilizzato per rimuovere quel calcare
dalla mia doccia dove scarico quando
scarico l'acqua del secchio che ho
appena utilizzato per lavare il
pavimento dove va a finire quel
detersivo o quel detersivo pieno di
schiuma che ho appena utilizzato per
pulire i piatti una volta che finisce
giù per i tubi dove va a finire
tutto ciò che entra nelle nostre case
sotto forma di bene
esce dalle nostre case sotto forma di
rifiuto il detersivo è un rifiuto
altamente inquinante e qui verrebbe da
dire va bene ok però siamo abituati così
da 70 anni da quando è stato inventato
il detersivo
adesso come facciamo tra poco c'è questo
countdown mondiale mancano sette anni
poco tempo abbiamo tante abitudini a
cambiare come possiamo fare beh oggi
vedremo insieme delle azioni concrete
per iniziare subito però prima vi faccio
alcune domande
la prima domanda è chi di voi usa già
detersivi ecologici per alzata di mano
chi di voi utilizza i classici rimedi
della nonna all'aceto il limone il
bicarbonato
chi di voi non ha mai sentito parlare di
pulizie ecologiche
per ognuno di noi andremo a vedere un
rimedio pratico da portarci a casa
subito ed iniziare già domani a pulire
in modo sano primo consiglio come pulire
gli scarichi mi stavo lavando i denti
con iris la mia bimba di tre anni è la
vedova residente e poi spazzolare con
energia lo scarico del lavandino poi si
riporta lo spazzolino alla bocca e
continua beatamente a spazzolare i denti
solo che per gli scarichi ci passano
residui di pelle di grasso non continua
la lista non è il mio intendo quello di
farvi prendere paura con le schifezze
che passano per gli scarichi ma quello
di fornirvi un rimedio per pulirli in
modo sano prima che si intasino che
vostro figlio si mette lì a pulirlo che
uno spazzolino quello che a tutti viene
in mente come rimedio è corro
nell'armadietto dei detersivi prendo
quel detersivo con la confezione
arancione che nel retro dell'etichetta
ciatti il teschio la croce il teschio
l'immagine dell'albero morto stecchito e
del pesciolino ammazzato d'altronde se
amazon pesce voi che non riesca a pulire
anche lo scarico del lavandino e invece
no el azione sbagliata perché il casa
probabilmente già voi avete due
ingredienti naturali che vengono in
nostro aiuto
vi basterà del bicarbonato e dell'aceto
l'operazione è semplice basta mettere
del bicarbonato all'interno dello
scarico svuotare 200 ml di aceto e
partirà un azione chimica che fa sì che
lo scarico risulti pulito ma quello che
andremo a scaricare in acqua sarà
semplicemente risivi di sali e di acqua
della reazione chimica il secondo
consiglio ammorbidenti ecologici
parliamo di ammorbidente che tra l'altro
non è neanche un detersivo o a un certo
punto è stato introdotto come abitudine
di tutti noi l'utilizzo
dell'ammorbidente per spiegare il motivo
dobbiamo parlare del pht ph è quel
valore che sopra 7 si dice che basico
sotto a 7 si dice che è acido tutti i
detersivi ha un ph basico quindi vuol
dire che a fine lavaggio
con quello che tiriamo fuori dal
lavatrice è un campo un vestito con un
ph basico la nostra pelle però ha un ph
leggermente acido dh sei appena sotto il
sette quindi per riportare il ph del
capo al ph neutro con la nostra bella è
stato introdotto l'ammorbidente e
l'ammorbidente appunto è leggermente
acido tutto questo per dirvi che potete
eliminare dalla vostra abitudine
l'utilizzo dell'ammorbidente e
sostituirlo con una soluzione di acqua e
acido citrico l'acido citrico è un
ingrediente ecologico di facilissimo
reperimento si trova tranquillamente in
internet in farmacia
addirittura il consorzio agrario e nei
piccoli negozi bio vi basterà prendere
150 g di questa polvere cristallina
aggiungerci dell'acqua un litro e
miscelare un pochino quello che avrete
ottenuto è un ammorbidente naturale che
potrete iniziare ad utilizzare
esattamente nello stesso modo con cui
fino a un attimo prima utilizzavate
l'ammorbidente tradizionale il terzo
rimedio detersivi ecologici
esistono già delle soluzioni pronti
pronte facile che tutti possiamo
cominciare a utilizzare immediatamente è
rimedio per tutte quelle persone che
dicono non voglio fare la piccola maga
magò della chimica o il giovane mago
merlino e mettermi a fare questo in tre
di queste pozioni magiche è già
disponibile
basta andare nei supermercati e
cominciare a cercare nelle corsie dei
detersivi
lo trovate nei negozi biologici oppure
lo potete cercare online per oggi vi do
tre consigli per essere sicuri che
quello che state per portare a casa è un
vero detersivo ecologico consiglio
numero uno cercate la scritta detersivo
ecologico può sembrare strano ma parole
come naturale con ingredienti di origine
vegetale con ingredienti di origine
naturale significano tutto e niente è di
origine naturale anche il petrolio
il secondo consiglio cercate la lista
degli ingredienti
siamo abituati a vederla nelle
confezioni di bagnoschiuma degli shampoo
dei saponi di quei di quelle sostanze
che vengono direttamente a contatto con
il nostro corpo è un'informazione che
viene data per tutelare il consumatore
per danni maggiori informazioni per la
scelta corretta del prodotto che gli
serve non è obbligatoria nei detersivi
nei detersivi c'è una cosa completamente
diversa che è la composizione chimica i
produttori di detersivi ecologici
utilizzano questa indicazione quindi
linci nemo gli ingredienti per offrire
una maggiore tutela del consumatore se
la trovata è molto probabile che quello
che avete tra le mani è un vero
detersivo ecologico è la comunicazione
che fa dire non abbiamo nulla da
nascondere
questo è un detersivo ecologico
ultimo consiglio le certificazioni
quindi o riassunti alcuni questa slider
principali le più facce di quelli che ho
trovato immediatamente ma anche qui
internet ci viene in aiuto
basterà a cercare un attimino sarà
facile trovarne altre se su un detersivo
c'è una di queste certificazioni potete
stare tranquilli che è un detersivo
ecologico
abbiamo visto delle soluzioni facili
concrete immediate non di difficile
reperimento non serve fare molto sforzo
per cambiare questa abitudine abbiamo
visto tre consigli che ognuno di voi può
portare a casa oggi e da domani iniziare
a cambiare un comportamento almeno un
comportamento e fare la propria parte
per un mondo migliore
sono le singole azioni le piccole azioni
di ognuno di noi che fanno la differenza
per salvare il nostro pianeta
mi auguro che le portate a casa e che da
domani anche voi possiate dire ho
salvato un pesciolino rosso
[Applauso]